[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend am
Tag danach in einer schon jetzt
politisch veränderten Republik was ich
vor allem daran zeigt wer jetzt in die
Offensive geht Grüne und FDP drehen den
Spieß um und übernehmen die Initiative
ohne die großen die ja eh keine großen
mehr sind das ist die interessanteste
Bewegung die sich gestern Abend schon
abzeichnete ein gemeinsames ausbrechen
aus dem bislang üblichen Formationstanz
die zwei kleineren ziehen ihre Kreise
erstmal allein und lassen die beiden
größeren warten dazu gleich noch ein
Gespräch mit einem der beiden
Tangotänzer Robert Habeck schauen wir
aber erstmal noch aufs vorläufige
Endergebnis so viel Zeit muss sein
die SPD gewinnt erheblich dazu und liegt
vorn mit 25,7 Prozent die Union stürzt
ab auf ein historisch schlechtes
Ergebnis von 24,1 Prozent Platz 3 für
die Grünen mit starken Gewinnen auf 14,8
die FDP verbessert sich leicht auf
11,5%. die AFD hingegen fällt zurück auf
den fünften Platz mit
10,3%. die Linke schafft gerade mal 4,9
Prozent bleibt aber trotzdem im
Bundestag dank drei Direktmandaten
Politik brauche eine Erzählung heißt es
in Berlin immer wieder sprachlich ist
das eine etwas schiefe eindeutung des
Lateinischen Narrativs aber Politikern
und Journalisten wird ja immer gesagt
sie sollten nicht so viele Fremdwörter
benutzen und so wird allen treiben nach
Erzählungen gesucht die politischen
Entscheidungen ein höheres Ziel und
einen tieferen Sinn verleihen
Koalitionen zum Beispiel den 80er Jahren
war Schwarz-Gelb die Wände in den 90ern
nannte sich Rot-Grün ein Projekt jetzt
sind FDP und Grüne auf der Suche nach
einem gemeinsamen Thema denn einfach nur
zu sagen wir wollen auch mal wieder mit
regieren und haben die Macht dazu wäre
keine gute erzählung
Zukunft und Politik für die junge
Generation Klängen schon besser man darf
sehr gespannt sein wie die Erzählung
ausgeht Thomas Reichert über den
Paartanz der Königsmacher
wie sich die Macht verschiebt nach der
Wahl dafür ist diese Pressekonferenz ein
bemerkenswertes Beispiel Annalena
baerbock war die spitzenfrau Robert
Habeck der unterlegen im Ringen um die
erste grüne Kanzlerkandidatur und jetzt
das persönliche Verhältnis ist gut
stabil intakt und vertrauensvoll wie eh
und je das haben wir vor Monaten genauso
besprochen dass wir wenn der Wahlkampf
vorbei ist wir gemeinsam als
Parteivorsitzende diese Sondierung
führen und auch alle sonstigen Fragen
bei uns selbstverständlich geklärt
worden sind beide also wieder zurück auf
Augenhöhe nur welche Fragen dann noch
geklärt wurden das wollen beide heute
nicht verraten nach zdf-information ist
es unter anderem diese Habeck soll bei
einer Regierungsbeteiligung Vizekanzler
werden nicht der Bock mit vertauschenden
Rollen also verhandeln die beiden
spitzengrünen nun die Machtoption mit
SPD oder Union
mit Blick auf die letzten Stunden wo die
Union ja gerade selber dabei ist sich
aus der Regierungsfähigkeit ein Stück
weit zu verabschieden gibt es eine
gewisse Logik die Gespräche mit SPD und
FDP
jetzt zu führen das heißt aber nicht
dass wir mit der Union nicht reden
werden erst bevor Sondierungen soll es
nun mit der FDP geben voraussichtlich am
Mittwoch engster Kreis nur die beiden
Spitzen Grünen mit FDP-Parteichef
Lindner und Generalsekretär Wissing das
gab es noch nie das erst die kleinen
miteinander reden dünnes Eis für alle
Beteiligten allein schon die Frage nach
der Dauer dieser Vorgespräche sorgt für
langes Schweigen
ich habe mit Herrn Harbeck noch nicht
verabredet was genau wir über den
Charakter dieser Gespräche öffentlich
kommunizieren wollen und deshalb will
ich die Frage zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
nicht beantworten einfach werden die
Gespräche nicht zu konträr sind die
Position besonders bei Steuern und
Finanzen zwischen Grünen und FDP gibt es
die größten inhaltlichen Unterschiede
bei den Parteien des demokratischen
Zentrums die jetzt über eine
Regierungsbildung miteinander sprechen
könnten deshalb macht es Sinn angesichts
dieser bisweilen bestehenden
Polarisierung den gemeinsamen Grund zu
suchen aber immerhin hat mit der FDP
2017 in Schleswig-Holstein schon einmal
eine Koalition mitverhandelt
entscheidend sei findet er dass man sich
vertraue
das Kabinett selber muss ja auch eine
verschworene Gemeinschaft werden aber
hey es kann was Neues entstehen
Deutschland Hallo schlaft ihr noch es
können was Neues entstehen ist ja
eigentlich eine coole Situation also
vielleicht mit dem Spirit da reinzugehen
kann ja auch eine Energie Freise setzen
und auf die setzen wir allzu viel Zeit
bleibt den kanzlermachern von Grünen und
FDP nicht die SPD hat schon klar gemacht
dass sie möglichst bald gerne mitreden
würde
und Robert Habeck ist sonst aus Berlin
zugeschaltet guten Abend Herr Habeck
guten Abend wenn sich jetzt die beiden
kleineren da treffen oder sondieren oder
vor sondieren Benutzer jeder so seine
eigenen Vokabeln ist das auch ein
Zeichen der Macht an die beiden größeren
auf uns kommt es an und wir haben jetzt
erstmal das sagen nein das ist ein
Zeichen der politischen Vernunft dass
die Parteien die nach der politischen
weltenlehre erst einmal weit auseinander
sind das sind Grüne und FDP in vielerlei
Punkten dass die erstmal schauen wie man
miteinander klar kommt das ist ein
Zeichen von Erwachsener Politik wann
treffen sie sich denn das erste Mal mit
Herrn Lindner das darf ich Ihnen nicht
sagen der Spiegel meldete vorhin am
Mittwoch das Spiegel weiß auch nicht
immer alles
ja aber oft auch vieles falsch also der
Hintergrund ist ganz klar solche
Gespräche brauchen ein vertrauensraum
ein vertrauensraum muss man herstellen
die muss man schützen diskretion ist ein
hohes Gut und Indiskretion ist die Pest
und deswegen
appelliere ich an alle und ich würde
mich daran halten nicht was Hinweis zum
Akte zu tragen das war ja auch beim
letzten Mal bei den
jamaika-verhandlungen die dann so
grandios und spektakulär scheiterten
auch das Hauptproblem das ständig
irgendwas von drinnen nach draußen
getragen wurde Smartphones Zeitalter
geht das noch leichter meinen sie das
können sie diesmal verhindern es war
eins der Hauptprobleme und ich bin mir
sicher dass es verhinderbar ist ja
trotzdem fragen sich auch viele
Zuschauer die jetzt nicht so in
Politbetrieb verhaftet sind wie manche
Journalisten und Politiker sowieso was
abläuft also ruft talentner Sie an oder
schickt er ihnen eine WhatsApp und sagt
Robert also sie nutzen sich ja wie
machen wir das jetzt und vor allen
Dingen wann fängt sowas an doch nicht
erst seit gestern Abend oder
na alle politischen Akteure haben
natürlich ihre Telefonnummern und dann
das Wahlkampf hat man sich hin und
wieder getroffen und
einerseits ist es ein kompliziertes
Geschäft weil eben jede Absprache jede
Vereinbarung immer gleich Auswirkungen
in viele andere Räume hat das ist
irgendwas anderes als ob sich zwei Leute
zum Kaffeetrinken oder zum ins Kino
gehen verabreden sondern da werden
gleich unmittelbar Wellen ausgelöst
deswegen muss man macht jede jede jede
jede Handbewegung sozusagen mehr Arbeit
je mehr man arbeitet desto mehr Arbeit
entsteht das ist ja das verrückte bei
der Politik oder andererseits ist es
dann doch ganz normal wir sind normale
Menschen die miteinander telefonieren
reden und sich vereinbaren und versuchen
das Beste rauszuholen wie jeder andere
Mensch ein Problem beim letzten mal war
also was in meiner Beobachtung nach dass
man versuchte wirklich jeden
spiegelstrich schon bei den
Sondierungsgesprächen zu lösen wollen
sie das diesmal anders angehen also so
eine überwölbendes Thema vielleicht
finden Zukunft Aufbruch das sind ja so
die Begriffe die man häufiger hört
nun die letzten Sondierungen 2017 auf
Bundesebene waren in vielerlei Hinsicht
die Folie wie man es nicht machen soll
dazu gehört sicherlich auch das unklare
was das eigentlich war es waren
Sondierungen sind eigentlich dazu da den
politischen Willen festzustellen und
dann muss man ja oder nein sagen und
wenn man ja gesagt hat committet man
sich auch über die
koalitionsverhandlungsphase hinaus man
ist ja dann am Ende in einer Regierung
die vier Jahre mindestens bestehen soll
und da werden jede Menge
Herausforderungen Krisen kommen die eben
nicht geplant sind immer muss dann eben
auch den Willen haben beieinander zu
bleiben ist dieser Wille da ja oder nein
das ist die sondierungsphase und beim
letzten Mal 2017 hat sich das ganz
unglücklich vermengt mit langen
spiegelstrichlisten und dann wurde auch
noch aufgefordert schreibt mal alles auf
was euch nicht gefällt aneinander und
dann schreibt man das alles auf das ist
so als ob man sich in der Partnerschaft
aufzählt was man doof findet aneinander
und dann sagt so und jetzt machen wir
einen schönen Urlaub zusammen aber du
Schnarch du lässt die Socken bei
rumliegen und Pampers die Milch im
Kühlschrank aber jetzt ab nach Mallorca
das wird nie was werden deswegen besser
ist positiv daran zu gehen und zu
schauen was kann es geben wenn wir jetzt
bei dieser Beziehungsebene dieser Meta
verbleiben dann kann es ja auch sein
dass sie sich schlichten ergreifen nicht
einigen denn Grüne und FDP liegen
relativ weit auseinander macht es dann
noch Sinn im dritten dazu zu holen oder
kann man es dann eigentlich auch gleich
lernst lassen nein das macht absolut
Sinn miteinander dann irgendwann zu
dritt zu reden es wird sicherlich so
sein dass Grüne und FDP miteinander
reden und sicherlich wird die SPD mit
der FDP reden und wir mit der SPD und
die CDU wird sicherlich auch noch mal
einladen und dann gibt es irgendwann
dreiergespräche und es muss am Ende ja
ein Gesamtkunstwerk ein Gesamtkonstrukt
sein das ist keine Regierung ist wo sich
nur zwei gegen einen verbünden oder zwei
ist hinkriegen man muss nur versuchen
richtig reinzukommen und dann muss es
eine Bewegung geben die aus dem
richtigen Staat heraus das bestmögliche
macht das heißt also es ist kein
exklusives verhandeln nur wir es geht
darum die Schraube gerade reinzusetzen
und nicht von vornherein schräg
reinzudrehen dann kann das kann der
Dübel niemals halten sehen sie sich dann
an Platz 2 also Sie haben ja etwas mehr
Prozentpunkte als die FDP wenn es dann
zum Beispiel auch darum geht den
heiligen Gral das Finanzministerium und
die Vizekanzlerschaft an sein das ist
jetzt nicht der entscheidende die
entscheidende Frage die entscheidende
Frage ist gibt es eine Idee ein eine
politische Identität stiftende Aufgabe
für diese Regierung oder wird es eine
Regierung die dann immer nur im kleinen
und kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner und dem
gegenseitigen ausbremsen verharrt das
ist die allererste und wichtigste Frage
wenn die positiv beantwortet wird wird
man für alle anderen Fragen eine Lösung
finden und Ressort zu Schnitte und
Personen zu den Ressorts ist dann immer
ganz am Ende zu verhandeln aber um
versehen Personen geht es natürlich auch
und da wird es dann auch nicht
philosophisch also Politik ist kein
Streichelzoo Frau baerbock hat keinen
guten Wahlkampf gemacht werden sie dann
jetzt das Zepter übernehmen ich meine
sie redet ja ständig von Robert und mir
plötzlich ist die Doppelspitze zurück
angela hat ein höchst engagierten
kämpferischen Wahlkampf gemacht das
Ergebnis ist nicht ganz da wo wir es
haben wollen das hat sie selber ja auch
gesagt aber sie setzt sich natürlich
voll ins Zeug geworfen und wir führen
jetzt die Verhandlungen gemeinsam dafür
sind wir gewählt worden das ist der
Wunsch und Wille der Partei und so
werden wir es machen und alle weiteren
sagen werden dann geklärt bzw
beantwortet werden wenn sie anstehen
aber sie sind jetzt quasi der
Verhandlungsführer so wirkt das so hört
man es auch aus ihrer Partei und wie man
in Berlin sagt nachtigalliquidia trapsen
wir führen die Verhandlung gemeinsam
okay danke für das Gespräch ich danke
Ihnen
kurz vor der Sendung aufgezeichnet um
noch mal auf den Begriff Erzählung
zurückzukommen Armin Laschet hatte
gestern auch eine Erzählung parat die
sich ungefähr so zusammenfassen lässt
mein Ergebnis ist zwar desaströs aber
die SPD ist ja auch nur 20 plus wir
bleiben Kanzler dass die SPD gewaltig
dazu gewonnen hat während die Union
gewaltig verloren hat ließ er dabei
geflissentlich weitgehend außen vor
angriff ist die beste Verteidigung heute
klang das allerdings schon etwas leiser
wohl auch weil vielen in der Union über
Nacht das ganze Ausmaß der Verluste
schmerzhaft bewusst geworden ist bei den
Direktmandaten wurde sie regelrecht
kannibalisiert auch prominente cdu-leute
verloren ihre Wahlkreise Julia Klöckner
zum Beispiel tritt in Rheinland-Pfalz
nicht noch mal an als CDU-Chefin Michael
Sack gibt in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern auf
und den Taschen der bayerischen
Schwestern sind eh die Messe auf die
Union am Tag danach Winnie und mattes
Feldhoff berichten
ein letztes Mal durchsaugen gleich will
auf dieser Bühne der CDU-Vorsitzende
seinen Ruf retten seinen Kritikern
entgegentreten sein politisches
Überleben sichern doch vor der Tür braut
sich längst ein Sturm zusammen angeführt
von den ostdeutschen
die Grundhaltung dass wir weitermachen
wie bisher muss ins Verderben führen
deswegen braucht es jetzt erst einmal
ein Innehalten das war für uns in
Ostdeutschland ein katastrophal
schlechtes Ergebnis und da brauchen wir
uns eine Aufarbeitung wir haben ein
Ergebnis erzielt dass ich mir vor
wenigen Monaten noch nicht einmal in den
schlimmsten Albträumen vorstellen konnte
und deshalb werden wir jetzt hinter
verschlossenen Türen über die
notwendigen Maßnahmen zur Neuaufstellung
der CDU inhaltlich und auch in jeder
anderen Hinsicht sprechen doch von
Neuaufstellung ist auf der Bühne nicht
zu sehen statt einem neuen steht da der
alte am Pult laviert und taktiert
die Frage ist ja führt man mit 24
Prozent ein Gespräch aus der Position
der Schwäche oder der Stärke und mit 25%
ein völlig andersgespräch also Olaf
Scholz und ich sind finde ich zur
gleichen Demut aufgehoben in der Wirkung
scheint das anders zu sein aber auch mit
25 Prozent hat man nicht den Anspruch
ich bin der nächste Kanzler und jetzt
müssen wir mal gerade gucken wie wir die
anderen mit dazu kriegen
Laschet begibt sich in die Hände von
Grünen und FDP sollen die doch
entscheiden ob Sie lieber mit ihm oder
Olaf Scholz seine Koalition wollen
selten begab sich ein CDU-Vorsitzender
so in Abhängigkeit
600 Kilometer entfernt wird Laschet
argwöhnisch beobachtet noch letzte Woche
wollten sie in der CSU nur als
Wahlsieger in Koalitionen inzwischen
akzeptiert man hier auch Platz 2 es ist
ein sehr sehr schwieriges Wahlergebnis
und das ist ein Wahlergebnis das
aus meiner Sicht eine der unnötigsten
Niederlagen der vergangenen Jahrzehnten
bedeutet von meiner Seite uns gibt es
keine Rückspiele keinen Groll ganz im
Gegenteil wir sehen die Ernsthaftigkeit
Herausforderung aber wir müssen schon
einmal noch mal aufarbeiten was war denn
französische Strauß hat immer gesagt
noch schlimmer als ein schlechtes
Wahlergebnis sind die falschen Lehren
die man daraus zieht doch Lehren heute
Fehlanzeige die Union verweigert sich
den Konsequenzen stattdessen lässt sie
Laschet laufen soll er es doch mal
probieren es hat auch in der Sitzung
keiner daran Zweifel geäußert dass die
Union in dieser Lage ihre Bereitschaft
zur Regierungsbildung erklären muss
erster oder zweiter 24 Prozent oder 25
Prozent die Union zeigt mal wieder dass
ihr nur eines wirklich wichtig ist die
Macht
dass ich vor allem Sachsens
Ministerpräsident Kretsch war so scharf
heute äußerte kommt nicht von ungefähr
die Verluste im Osten sind für die CDU
besonders krass sie verlor wahlweise an
die AFD oder an die SPD was hier
strategisches Dilemma dort auf den Punkt
bringt der Kandidat aus dem tiefen
Westen konnte das offenkundig nicht
überwölben Thomas Berg spricht
es ist mehr als nur eine Krisensitzung
heute Abend bei den CDU Gremien in
Dresden wie sollte es auch anders sein
angesichts des Wahlergebnisses gestern
für die Sachsen war es ein Debakel das
nur einen einzigen Schluss zulässt und
den sprechen Sie hier auch aus wähle
Auftrag ist nicht regieren sondern
Oppositionen und das muss man indem man
annehmen und ich glaube das ist noch
nicht gänzlich zu jedem durchgedrungen
in der Grafik färbt sich Sachsen fast
flächendeckend blau in allen ländlichen
Wahlkreisen verloren die CDU
Direktkandidaten gegen die AFD ähnlich
im benachbarten Thüringen auch hier traf
sich heute der Landesvorstand auch die
erste Analyse hier kommt nicht ohne
kleine Spitze aus das lag an
inhaltlichen Themen ich glaube auch dass
die Themen in den neuen Bundesländern zu
wenig adressiert wurden im Wahlkampf es
lag an organisatorischen Gründen aber
nicht zuletzt auch am Spitzenkandidaten
doch es lag womöglich nicht nur an der
Person Armin Lasche sondern an den
Umständen seiner Inthronisierung viele
in der CDU hätten lieber Markus Söder
gesehen Laschet ein ungeliebter Kandidat
die Diskussion darüber scheint manchen
etwas lästig das hilft ja jetzt nicht
weiter wir haben bei diesem Wahlkampf
der ja extrem schwierig war es nicht
geschafft die Geschlossenheit zu zeigen
die man braucht um am Ende auch viele
Wählerinnen und Wähler zu überzeugen
Geschlossenheit von einer Basis
verlangen die übergangen wurde wie sehr
sich manche brüskiert fühlten zeigte die
CDU im sächsischen Bad Lausick der
Stadtverband hatte sich nach laschets
Kür sogar offen geweigert für den
kandidatenwahlkampf zu machen für
Plakate müsse Armin Laschet hier selbst
auf die Leiter steigen hieß es in einem
offenen Brief Udo Görke wusste Laschet
ist seinen Wählern hier nicht
vermittelbar und Söder hatte bundesweit
auch noch die besseren Werte
da hätte ich von Herrn Laschet auch
erwartet dass er als Politprofi als
jemand der schon jahrelang im Geschäft
ist dass er das erkennt dass das Beste
für die Partei wäre und für die Union
wenn es daher Söder macht weil der
einfach das Standing hatte dort in der
Bevölkerung doch nicht nur für die
cdu-wahlkämpfer auch bei der
Wählerschaft im Osten traf die
Entscheidung pro Laschet womöglich einen
empfindlichen Nerv ich glaube das ist
für viele potenzielle Wählerinnen und
Wähler das berühmte i-Tüpfelchen war
also das hat ihnen noch einmal
signalisiert dass man eigentlich an
ihnen also jedenfalls vermeintlich in
ihrer Wahrnehmung kein Interesse hat
weil ihr offenkundig eben der Kandidat
der Herzen der Kandidat nicht zuletzt
der ostdeutschen Landesverbände gerade
nicht nominiert wurde
die Aufarbeitung des wahlsonntags nimmt
in der CDU Fahrt auf nicht nur im Osten
tja Schock im Osten für die Union Theo
call aber ja nicht nur dort haben
Michael Kretschmer nicht der einzige der
heute durchblicken ließ wir über dieses
waldesaster denkt wie viel Wut wird da
noch unterdrückt weil man eben den
Erhalt des Kanzleramts nicht noch mehr
gefährden will durch Streit
ja ich glaube davon darf man ausgehen
dass das passiert in gewisser Weise ist
die Aussicht auf eine mögliche
Jamaika-Koalition aktuell noch die beste
politische Lebensversicherung für Armin
Laschet verstärkt hier durch sein
besonderes Vertrauensverhältnis zu
FDP-Chef Christian Lindner niemand in
der Union möchte dann am Ende dafür
verantwortlich gemacht werden dass diese
letzte macht Option und damit die Option
aufs Kanzleramt wegfällt und dennoch
wackelt der Deckel auf diesem brodelnden
Topf schon ein gefährlich vielen Stellen
der Ministerpräsident von Sachsen-Anhalt
sprach ja von Desaster Jens Spahn
fordert eine Verjüngung der Parteispitze
und Wirtschaftsminister Peter Altmaier
eine Art Neuaufstellung der Union also
eine vize-fraktionsvorsitzende aus
Rheinland-Pfalz hat sogar Lasche
zurücktritt gefordert ob der Deckel also
auf dem Topf bleibt ist längst noch
nicht ausgemacht also muss Armin Laschet
eigentlich ins Kanzleramt um seine
eigenen politische Karriere zu retten
oder sein politisches Überleben
ja das wäre jedenfalls für ihn die
sicherste Variante ohne den Ausweg
müsste Armin Laschet mindestens
Zweikämpfe gewinnen a den aktuellen
Kampf um die Deutungshoheit des
Wahlergebnisses und seiner Ursachen also
hat er nach diesem Wahlergebnis
überhaupt noch einen Anspruch auf die
Führung der Partei und auf eine mögliche
Regierungsbildung und der zweite Kampf
ist schlicht der um die innerparteiliche
macht und da wird es spannend wie die
morgige Wahl des Fraktionsvorsitzenden
abläuft denn das wird der mächtigste
Posten der Union falls Sie es nicht ins
Kanzleramt schafft eigentlich wollte
Laschet die Wahl noch aufschieben und
Zeit zu gewinnen das aber hat der
Amtsinhaber Ralf Brinkhaus abgelehnt er
möchte morgen wiedergewählt werden dann
aber könnten auch andere politische
Schwergewichte antreten der Machtkampf
in der Union läge damit dann offen zu
Tage also der gestrige Wahltag war alles
nur kein Schlusspunkt
die SPD präsentiert sich hingegen heute
in einem genießermodus in Bund auf Platz
1 nach einer wirklich unglaublichen
auffolljagd in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
ein echtes volksparteiergebnis für
Manuela Schwesig und auch bei der
Berlinwahl hat die SPD den Sieg davon
getragen so gut ging es den
Sozialdemokraten nach wahlabenden schon
lange nicht mehr
allerdings kann es Olaf Scholz nicht
gefallen wie die beiden potenziellen
Koalitionspartner sich jetzt schnuppern
nach dem Motto mal sehen wer am Ende
unter uns regiert wie er die FDP von
einer Ampel überzeugen will ist eh offen
lass Bohnsack und Andreas Fuhrpark
berichten
SPD Ortsverein Ludwigsfelde tief in
Brandenburg auf den Wahlerfolg ihrer
Partei sind sie stolz die Haltung
gegenüber einer Ampelkoalition aber ist
gemischt die SPD sollte jetzt schon
zeigen dass wir den Regierungsauftrag
bekommen haben wir sind die stärkste
Fraktion und es sollte sich nicht wieder
so hinziehen wie vor vier Jahren die FDP
wird diesmal ist auch schwerer haben
sich wieder aus der Verantwortung zu
ziehen tatsächlich eher 50 50 für eine
Ampelkoalition weil ich tatsächlich die
große ja Anbiederung der FDP an die CDU
schon nach der Wahl gesehen habe Olaf
Scholz sagt es durch die Blume rot-gelb
und grün seine lieblingskonstellation
die Ampel soll es werden mit FDP den
Grünen und ihm als Kanzler
wenn also drei Parteien die den
Fortschritt am Beginn der 20er Jahre im
Blick haben sich zusammentun dann kann
das etwas Gutes werden selbst wenn sie
dafür unterschiedliche Ausgangslagen
haben zumal sich die Ausgangslagen für
einige in der parteifundamental geändert
haben die SPD linke setzte nämlich lange
Zeit auf Rot-Rot-Grün allen voran die
Parteichefin die Linkspartei ist raus da
muss man sich flexibel zeigen und es war
immer meine Überzeugung dass wir dazu
auch Parteien brauchen die sich zum
einen vertrauen die zum anderen aber
auch einen Auftrag von Wählerinnen und
Wählern haben wir freuen uns sehr auf
die Zusammenarbeit und auf die Gespräche
die jetzt anstehen auffallend anders als
gegenüber der Linkspartei vor der Wahl
werden gegenüber der FDP rote Linien
bislang vermieden alles soll und muss
auf den Tisch nur so könne ein
funktionierendes Bündnis geschmiedet
werden wir sind alle gut beraten das
gilt aber dann für alle Seiten dass wir
aufeinander zugehen und ausloten was für
dieses Land wichtig ist und das ist vor
allem dass es ein Aufbruch gibt der
gerecht ist aber der eben auch Kräfte
freisetzt Ovationen für den Mann der der
SPD eine Menge neue Mandate verschafft
hat um 54 Abgeordnete ist die
Bundestagsfraktion gewachsen und gibt
sich selbstbewusst das Gesprächsangebot
in Richtung der möglichen
Koalitionspartner klingt hier eher nach
Peitsche als nach Zuckerbrot
die FDP muss sich gut überlegen ob sie
erneut diese Republik in eine
Warteschleife schicken will oder ob sie
eben bereit ist Gestaltungskraft
gestaltungswellen in eine
reformkoalition einzubringen für die die
Sozialdemokratische Partei unverzichtbar
ist eine Ampel mit FDP und Grünen wird
kein Selbstläufer das dürfte auch Olaf
Scholz klar sein mit großen Widerstand
in der SPD muss er aber wohl auch nicht
rechnen
wer gestern in der Hauptstadt wählen
ging bzw wählen gehen wollte traute
vielerort seinen Augen nicht hunderte
Meter lange Schlangen das kennt man aus
anderen Ländern etwa den USA aus
Deutschland eigentlich nicht
Doris kam noch schlimmer in einigen
Ämtern gingen die Wahlzettel aus konnte
ich ja keiner mit rechnen dass da bei
einer Bundestagswahl so viele kommen
manche standen stundenlang tapfer an
andere Gaben irgendwann auf in einem
Wahllokal wurden wahlwillige sogar nach
Hause geschickt nun sind die Berliner
Kummer gewöhnt dass man zum Beispiel auf
Ämtern keine Termine bekommt normal aber
dass die deutsche Hauptstadt nicht mal
in der Lage ist Wahlen zu organisieren
das ist ein neuer Tiefpunkt aus Berlin
Nils Schneider und Roman Lesko war
der Tag danach die Plakate haben ihren
Dienst getan die Wahl wird für viele
Hauptstädte aber noch lange in
Erinnerung bleiben heftige Pannen in
einigen Wahllokalen
wir sind halb sechs der Hilde gegangen
in der Hoffnung dass man da quasi ohne
weiteres reinkommt und dann wie gesagt
also 50 Minuten haben wir gewartet und
das dann auch die Papiere ausgegangen
sind da die die Formulare und also
ich habe schon kein großes Vertrauen
mehr in das was noch kommt lange
gewartet habe ich erstaunlicherweise
also das habe ich so noch nie erlebt ich
habe mich gefragt liegt es jetzt an den
corona-regeln oder ist für richtig
erklären konnte ich mir nicht mehr bei
mir haben auch keine Wahlzettel gefehlt
eigentlich schien Berlin gut vorbereitet
es gab mehr Wahllokale und Wahlhelfer
und ausreichend Stimmzettel so die
Landeswahlleiterin am Morgen danach
wirkt sie nun ahnungs und ratlos schiebt
eine Mitschuld für das Chaos auf die
Bezirke das ganze Ausmaß müsse sie erst
prüfen die Wahl ist demokratisch wenn
alle Wählerinnen und Wähler von ihrem
Stimmrecht Gebrauch machen konnten und
wenn es dazu gekommen ist dass einige
Wähler gehindert waren habe ich ja schon
gesagt dann halte ich das für einen
relevanten Wahlfehler und dann liegt ein
Verstoß gegen wahlrechtliche
Bestimmungen vor halten Sie es für
wahrscheinlich dass die Wahl wiederholt
werden muss kann ich Ihnen noch nicht
sagen
drei von 12 Berliner Bezirken sollen
betroffen sein den Hauptstädtern wurde
viel Geduld abverlangt berichtet wird
sogar von Wählern die weggeschickt
wurden weil es keine Wahlzettel mehr gab
von den zuständigen Kommunalpolitikern
will sich heute keiner äußern Häme und
Spott dagegen bei der Opposition im
Abgeordnetenhaus
dieser Senat hat sich bis auf die
Knochen blamiert bei der Durchführung
einer Wahl in ganz Deutschland hat es
funktioniert in Berlin nicht wir müssen
endlich dieses
dysfunktionale abstellen und dafür
braucht es eine Regierung die das nicht
zur Kenntnis nimmt sondern die
entschlossen handelt Juristen sehen
ebenfalls einige gravierende Fehler eine
Neuwahl sei nach jetzigem Stand aber
nicht nötig wenn man jeden Fehler der
bei Wahlen passiert
so sanktionieren würde dass es dass die
Wahl angefochten werden und dann
aufgehoben wird dann würden wir in
Deutschland nie zu einem Ergebnis kommen
denn bei jeder Wahl passieren Fehler und
bei jeder Wahlwiederholung auch
so sind bislang auch keine Anfechtungen
bekannt was bleibt ist der bittere
Nachgeschmack Berlin kämpft weiter mit
dem Image einer schlecht
funktionierenden Stadt die neue
Landesregierung kann sich auf viel
Arbeit freuen
kein Mensch kann im Moment vorhersagen
wann eine neue Bundesregierung steht und
das macht vor allem der
wirtschaftssorgen Heinz führende
Wirtschaftsverbände haben vor einer
langen Regierungsbildung gewarnt was
sind da die Befürchtungen Frank beetmann
an der Börse in Frankfurt naja
tatsächlich kaum ein Statement heute bei
dem nicht gewarnt wurde es dürfte jetzt
keine Hängepartie geben die Wirtschaft
wünscht sich schnelle Entscheidungen vor
allem aber kluge Konzepte für eine
wirtschaftspolitische Neuausrichtung des
Landes denn es gebe dringend
Handlungsbedarf auf zahlreichen Feldern
wie etwa dem Klimaschutz der Zukunft
sicheren Finanzierung der Renten und
natürlich auch bei den schleppenden
Digitalisierung Unternehmer ab groß oder
klein fordern schnellere Genehmigungen
bei Planungsverfahren und dringend
niedrigere Steuern da auch mit weniger
war man heute schon zufrieden weitere
Steuererhöhungen oder einen schärferes
Eingreifen des Staates beispielsweise am
Immobilienmarkt sein wohl kein Thema
mehr so die Börsianer kleine
ausschusslorbeeren dafür vom DAX der am
Ende zumindest mit 42 Punkten im Plus
schließt überhaupt über Wok heute der
Pragmatismus ein Linksrutsch sei vom
Tisch und mit Blick auf die anstehenden
Sondierungsgespräche von Grün und FDP
meinte eine start-up-unternehmerin sehr
zuversichtlich die Grünen stehen für
ambitionierten Klimaschutz die Liberalen
für einen Klimaschutz mit schnellen
Genehmigungen aber soweit sind wir
natürlich noch nicht Frank Bethmann
vielen Dank
zu den coronazahlen in Deutschland das
Robert-Koch-Institut meldet 322
Neuinfektionen innerhalb von 24 Stunden
714 weniger als vor einer Woche es kann
man denn eines Tages 10 Todesfälle dazu
die sieben Tage Inzidenz liegt jetzt bei
61,7
ein starkes Erdbeben hat heute morgen
die griechische Insel Kreta erschüttert
dabei kam mindestens ein Mann ums Leben
mehrere Menschen wurden verletzt
besonders stark betroffen waren Dörfer
und kleine Städte in der unmittelbaren
Nähe des Epizentrums südlich von
Heraklion viele alte Steingebäude
stürzten ein aber auch neuere Häuser
wurden beschädigt Rettungskräfte suchen
weiter nach Verschütteten das Beben hat
er eine Stärke von mindestens 5,8 und
war auch noch an der Südwestküste der
Türkei zu spüren
die belarussische Oppositionelle Maria
kolesny Cover ist mit dem Butler favel
Menschenrechtspreis des Europarats
ausgezeichnet worden ihre Schwestern
nahmen die Auszeichnung in Straßburg
stellvertretend für die inhaftierte
Preisträgerin entgegen
kolesnikowa hatte nach der umstrittenen
Präsidentschaftswahl in Belarus Proteste
gegen Machthaber Lukaschenko angeführt
und wurde daraufhin zu elf Jahren
Gefängnis verurteilt
das Schicksal der Belarussen berührt
auch noch einmal besonders an einem Tag
nachdem wir hierzulande freie Wahlen
hatten mit diversen Oppositionsparteien
und einem offenen Wahlausgang mit denen
es in den nächsten Tagen noch viel zu
berichten gibt und um 0.25 Uhr meldet
sich Christopher Beermann mit unserem
heute schon mal Update auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
ein schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter das Blau was Sie
hier sehen dieser Regen der gehört zu
einer Kaltfront die uns relativ rasch
überquert und zwar nach Osten hin
dahinter setzt sich vorübergehend hoher
Luftdruck durch diese Kaltfront liegt in
der Nacht einmal quer überall
Deutschland und verlagert sich nun
allmählich nach Osten löst allerdings
auch örtlich Gewitter aus zum Beispiel
Richtung Ostsee im Westen wird es
deutlich ruhiger entsprechend bildet
sich hier Nebel im Südwesten ist auch
etwas Regen dabei Temperaturen sinken
nach Westen in auf 6 bis 9 Grad hier ist
es also schon spürbar Kühler hier ist
also die kältere Luft eingeflossen
deutlich milder vor der Kaltfront mit 14
Grad im Osten Deutschlands morgen im
Tagesverlauf verziehen sich dann die
Regenwolken nach Osten hin in der Mitte
gibt es durchaus viele Wolken und mal
Sonnenschein mehr Sonne Richtung Nordsee
oder am Oberrhein bei höchsten
Temperaturen im Süd werden dann bis 21
Grad am Niederrhein sind es dann 20 Grad
16 Richtung Osten oder teils 17 Grad das
sind dann die tiefsten Höchstwerte die
nächsten Tage werden ruppiger am
Mittwoch komm shower auf und vor allem
nach Nordwesten in Richtung Nordsee da
auch viel Wind bei 14 bis 20 Grad und
vor allem in der Nacht auf Donnerstag
kommt dann Sturm auf dieser Sturm wird
hauptsächlich dann erst einmal an der
Nordsee zu spüren sein bei 13 bis 18
Grad und am Freitag ist es dann wieder
ruhiger bis 21 Grad und damit ein
schöner Abend